les seigneurs sont discriminés
les plus jeunes sont discriminés
les femmes sont discriminées
et si t'as le malheur d'être enceinte
t'es encore plus discriminée
les handicapés sont discriminés
les malades sont discriminés les gros sont discriminés
les moches sont discriminés
les non-blancs sont discriminés
les noms français sont discriminés
les défavorisés sont discriminés
les gens émotifs
ou qui ont le malheur d'avoir fait un burn-out
sont discriminés
en fait pour les entreprises
dans l'idéal il faudrait que tous les salariés
soient des hommes
blancs entre trente et quarante-cinq ans qui
si possible
n'ont pas des gosses trop tôt et surtout qui
on le manifeste
des dirigeants
c'est-à-dire se donner corps et âme pour le travail
faire passer le travail avant tout
évidemment
être capable de résister à une forte pression
à un gros stress et ne pas tomber en burn-out
les mecs à aucun moment
ils disent que cette catégorie de salarié
exemplaire tend à disparaître
c'est-à-dire que même les hommes blancs
entre trente et quarante-cinq ans
commencent à dire merde au don de soi maintenant
mais ce qui est normal
les nouvelles générations
prennent la place des anciennes générations
petit à petit
et à partir des millénioles
on ne veut plus de cette mentalité
donc là en deux-mille-vingt-trois
on a encore énormément de discrimination au travail
et les dirigeants ne se rendent toujours pas compte
que la diversité des salariés
est une véritable opportunité pour leur entreprise
et encore une fois
parce qu'ils ne voient que le côté et rentabilité
profit productivité
performance et dans leur tête
en fait
toute cette catégorie de personnes que je vous ai dit
pour eux
ils sont beaucoup moins performants et productifs
que des hommes blancs entre eux
trente et quarante-cinq ans
c'est la diversité qui fait la force
en réunissant tous les mannequins
les logiques les compétences différentes qu'on décolle
on est tous différents sur cette planète
on a tous des logiques différentes
imaginez-vous
s'il y avait la même logique pour tout
tout le monde sur cette planète
en fait on aurait avancé à rien
on serait sûrement pas allé sur la lune
on aurait peu de connaissances en médecine
peut-être qu'on saurait même pas faire un bâtiment
bon ben un entreprise c'est pareil
si tout le monde a le même mannset que le dirigeant
l'entreprise elle va jamais décoller
y aurait aucune innovation
c'est logique non oui à la diversité
oui à l'inclusion et non à la discrimination